hello folks welcome thank you very much
everyone for attending
uh
we had intended for this to be an in
person we actually had intended for hugo
to speak to us last month in person
he got sick the day of and very wisely
bowed out and we filled in with kirill
mueller very happy that happened to be
in new york at that time and was able to
speak for us very lucky um chain of
events so then we intended for this meet
up to be in person this month if hugo
but our venue couldn't host us this
month
so
we're here virtually and when i say in
person i mean both virtually and in
person
we're always going to do it going
forward in the future but virtual and in
person so everyone around the world can
join us
we are hoping to be doing that this
month but we don't have a venue it
actually in these i don't want to say
post-covet times these during covet
times whatever it is the cova
transitional times whatever you want to
call these times
it's hard to find
spaces to hold us
so if you your company organization
would like to host the meetup on an
ongoing basis or even occasionally send
me a message you know how to find me on
twitter on linkedin on meetup.com on the
ny hacker slack my email at
jaredlander.com landonolympics.com
any way possible find a way to get in
touch with me say hi tell us you would
like to host the meetup i would be very
very excited about that
all right
so thank you everyone for being here
virtually and again hopefully at some
point soon both in person and virtual as
soon as we can find more venues to host
us in the past we had a number of
different places we'd rotate between so
please let's get that going again
the first thing i like to do when it's
in person which we had two in-person and
virtual meetups the past two months i
was very excited we could ask this i
asked who's hiring
since i know we can't all stand up and
say you're hiring please go to the mi
hacker slack which you can find at my
hackard.org
and go to the job postings channel and
post your job there let people know that
you're looking to hire and people who
want to get hired go there and find a
job
if you want to get hired by me go to my
website actually all the jobs aren't
posted but we're looking for an account
executive and a linux admin both of
those are posted and a data scientist
that's not posted but just apply for the
shiny dev close enough we'll get it
posted eventually so if you want to
learn more about the jobs i offer
contact me or go to landeranalytics.com
careers
and again please go to jobs the jobs
channel on in my hacker and post it
another thing we are missing out on by
not having an in-person component
is fabulous new york city pizza
so i got my pizza today from vito's see
i got a square slice
and i got a round slice
there's good cheese lock but you know
it's been sitting for a little bit so of
course it's gonna be good here too good
cheese lock see this was made in a pan
and this was made right on the gas deck
oven
so please let us know in the chat where
you got your pizza from or whatever
other food you choose to eat today let
me know where it where you got it from
let us know what it is tell us all about
your meals about this fun stuff you're
doing i'd love to make you know people
who know me coming to the meetup know
that food is a big part of the meetup at
least pizza is
so
let me know join into the chat speaking
of chat either use the zoom chat right
here or in the ny hack our slack go to
the monthly meetup channel either place
is great to chat with us so let us know
this past uh week or two ago
we posted the videos from the new york r
conference we had the new york r
conference back in june uh june 9th and
10th the videos are up live you can find
them at rstats.ai
in fact if you go to rstats.ai you can
find videos from all the new york r
conferences and all the dcr and our gov
conferences up there so if you want to
check these out most of them are 20
minutes occasional few special ones are
40. nice quick easy go check them out
rstats.ai to find all these great videos
and we are very excited this isn't we
haven't announced this yet but we're at
the meetup now so i'm going to tell you
some things early december 1st through
2nd actually november 30th through
december 2nd so we have workshops uh the
art in government conference is
returning live both in person and
virtual
at georgetown we are very excited for
this we're going to make an official
announcement soon this isn't meant for
anyone who's involved with r or data
science because remember like this
meetup the conference even though it has
r in the name is our and friends we've
always been about open source data
whether that is r python sql julia go
stan c plus or just the math behind it
or
just the theory they're just the
practice it's r and friends so this for
anyone is using r or data science in the
practice of government that means
federal local state means international
you'd be working for government from
another country or
a province
or in public sector
if you work in the health care sector or
education this conference is for all of
you
if you'd like to give a talk we are
accepting um submissions or talks
message me tell me your idea if the
topic is good then we'll ask for an
abstract and if it passes the the um
litmus test i guess it's a [ __ ]
better word uh then you get to speak
it's a very um very friendly conference
any of you've been to any of the
conferences we put on you know what it's
like so december 1st through 2nd for the
conference and november 30th for the
workshops again both in person at
georgetown and virtual and hopkin
speaking of conferences um there is a
in october october 6th or 7th there is a
shiny in production conference in
newcastle uk uh that's put on by uh
friends of friends of ours jumping
rivers we uh we're fans of theirs they
are so they run a similar company to the
run that we run and we're friendly with
them and i'd like to everyone say if you
happen to be in newcastle go to the
shiny production
so
before we start the meetup first please
introduce yourselves let us know who you
are where you're coming from and if you
have questions
that you want to ask hugo please post it
either here in the zoom chat or in the
monthly meetup chat i mentioned before
in our slack
so
go there tell us what you're eating if
you have questions at the end of the
chat of the meetup i will take all the
questions and ask hugo the harder the
questions the better i want him to be
stumped by the end of this we want to
make sure that he doesn't know what's
going on here no but seriously
to stump me
all right quick everyone come up your
hardest math questions i wanted to prove
fermat's last theorem here all right
that's the goal so that that wasn't
nerdy enough for everybody i hope i hope
i hope we can get nerdier everyone
please give a warm virtual welcome to
hugo thank you very much for being here
hugo
thanks everyone
i have to apologize jared i actually
don't have any pizza to eat while
speaking but in my defense i had a bialy
for breakfast from kosovo
oh from coastal then that's good enough
you got a co-star bialy that's legit man
we have an awesome speaker here who used
to live in new york
and attend i first met him at the
conference the our conference i believe
not the meetup at the conference the
first archon the first the very first
art conference and hugo was a mainstay
in the new york community until he went
back down under he's been living there
he's have worked a number of many
different companies you probably heard
him from his podcast he's had a number
of very successful podcasts um
and he's awesome that's how i like to
introduce people
that is the best introduction i could
never have given myself so i appreciate
it very much and jared's jared's right
actually i um i started coming to this
meet up
when i lived in new haven connecticut
which what wasn't for me but when i
started coming to the meet up in the
city it really i was still working in
academic research and trying to figure
out how to get into in industry in a
variety of ways um and this meetup among
a few other places was so important for
me to meet people in the city to feel
part of a community and it still feels
like home so i just want to like give a
huge shout out to jared everyone who
works with jared the meetup and the
conferences and all the great work you
do and it's so so great to be back
thank you very much hugo that's really
nice it's good to have you and i'm
excited for this
yeah and so a bit of a bit more
background about me i i've i've worked
in data science in education data
science education ml education tool
building
um for a variety of in a variety of
startups and open source
uh frameworks and packages kind of my
origin story i i worked in basic
research in in science and i saw
i saw some of the best scientists of my
generation i seriously saw some of the
best scientists of many generations not
being able to do what what they needed
to do uh because of a serious lack of
tooling and education around tooling um
and i enjoyed
doing the science as much as i enjoyed
all the developer relations or the
advocacy all the tool building i i i do
but it struck me as the work that i
could do um in
education and developer relations was a
lot more impactful for me um and that's
actually why i've started working in
thinking more about machine learning
infrastructure i think this is one of
the most
let me say fragmented aspects of the
data science space we all work in so
trying to make headway there is
something i'm really interested in so
without further ado that's just a bit
about me i'll um
i'll share my screen i also do want to
ask a question
we're going to be talking about uh ml
ops and devops and why uh data makes it
different um
and why this kind of field of ml ops has
has emerged quote unquote hey max great
to see you man um very interested in
your thoughts on on this as well um
i
i would because we're really talking
about
operationalizing and productionizing
machine learning models i'd love to know
what that actually means to you um if so
if you could put in the chat and this is
this is not a trick question i think the
idea of productionizing or
operationalizing a model is it isn't
binary right it's not a yes or no i
don't even think it's necessarily a
spectrum i think it's this you know huge
multi-dimensional space that that means
different things to to different people
so if you could give a shout out or put
in put in the slack chat or
the zoom chat what operationalizing or
production means to you that would just
help me kind of um
give me some sort of compass and the
yardsticks so to speak um for who who's
here um so i just want to give a brief
origin story for operation
operationalizing uh machine learning i
work on a software called um
metaflow which was born out of out of
netflix um so i want to give a brief
origin story of what happened with
metaflow at netflix but this is
relatively generalizable
so in the beginning um
there wasn't light there were just
recommendations
um and and of course there's lots of
other things that machine learning and
we'll even talk about what machine
learning actually means um can
can do um and then it was suddenly like
oh we've got some natural language stuff
that may help us with certain things
there's computer vision of course when
thinking about um video data
we're customers um and it's a
subscription model uh we have customers
and there's a subscription model so we
need to think about predicting churn and
and the list goes on right so over time
at netflix a diverse set of use cases
for machine learning started started
popping up as we're seeing uh in a lot
of industries okay um so as
tool builders
um and working in education i think it's
really important to
a lot of it is pattern recognition right
so thinking about what is common across
all the different um ml uh ml projects
right so
what was happening
at netflix and a lot of other places as
we know all projects need data whether
it's tables text
image data uh looking at metrics these
these types of things this is common
across all projects
then a lot of projects need to execute
compute intensive uh algorithms at scale
so suddenly we may need some sort of uh
cloud resources or something along those
lines right
projects data science workflows um in
the end tend to consist of multiple
steps that need to be uh executed right
so maybe we need to orchestrate them in
in some way
when we reach this part of the
conversation um on top of this all
projects have developed iteratively
through multiple versions so suddenly
we're not only talking about
um versioning code maybe we're talking
about versioning models or versioning
data versioning software right um so
this becomes a concern and this may not
be a concern for absolutely everybody
but it's a big enough pattern that it's
something we need to um
reckon with as as a field and a
discipline right
all projects we can definitive almost
definitely say this um leverage
third-party libraries including a lot of
open source technologies as well right
so then the question really becomes
can we address all of these concerns um
in a single coherent framework and i
think the answer is
we can but we want it to be
interoperable um with a lot of other
existing uh frameworks and i think
that's something that we've seen in in
the space in increasingly um is
as opposed to having like all-in-one
platforms which serve the needs of a
data scientist which i actually don't
think in the short to medium term is
possible at all we're seeing collections
of the interoperable open source
frameworks and also uh commercial
offerings um
connect and form these these pipelines
so to speak
so
this this is important um but this is
from kind of the view of a tool maker in
a lot of ways i kind of spoke to some of
the data scientists concerns um and i've
already got a few responses to
this is great to what productionizing
machine uh learning means uh fred has
said automating uh complex processes
great uh marcus said operationalizing
means process is documented repeatable
procedures repeatable is a fantastic
term when we're thinking about
operationalizing or productionizing
derrick has said provide scalable data
infrastructure to interact with end
users so we have infrastructure we have
data infrastructure we have something be
um
scalable um we have repeatable we have
automation right these i mean i've just
said five
maybe these are like four dimensions if
we project down slightly um jared has
said check slack two so i'll definitely
do that
um chintan has said operationalizing
machine learning means
making inferences with a trained model
in a way that's fast
reliable
and scalable depending
on the use case brilliant um software
engineering best practices play into all
of these things it's a question what we
should adopt as data professionals from
software engineering best practices i
think you know of course
version control
um refactoring testing
um unit testing data testing um it's not
clear to me
whether
i don't want to start flame wars it's
not clear to me whether cicd is the best
um uh paradigm and a mental model for
what we want to do uh when
operationalizing machine learning models
so it's a good question what we want to
adopt from from software and engineering
um
awesome so we have a lot more coming in
and and i think we can definitely circle
back to them but
what i want to do given all of this is
kind of talk briefly about what a data
scientist does when
when they're going from prototype to
production okay
so
we want to take something from prototype
and productionizer whatever that may
mean right and what crops up there so
a lot of the time we start exploring in
notebooks uh okay um now
when i want to deploy code or something
along those lines i know there are a
subset of people who like to like doing
this wonderfully with with notebooks my
preference and a lot of people's i mean
i'm already starting another flame more
clearly um is to
um is to then script convert my
exploratory data analysis and first
models into some form of script um with
some form of workflow right and so this
may be um doing some basic orchestration
writing a dag something something along
these lines okay
um
then you want to start thinking about
versioning as we talked about before if
you're um let's say you've got three
models that you're trying to train uh in
parallel to see which performs best and
you're updating them uh according to
different data sets or whatever it may
be we want to start versioning these
things and
so that we're able to reference them
later on right
um
then we might want to scale vertically
we may want to like use one um really
large compute instance to see how our
model works on as much data as possible
um if our dataset gets big enough or we
want to do a lot of parallel training
maybe we want to scale
horizontally to uh leverage
clusters right
we may want to access data super quickly
and this is actually a huge challenge
right because when we're prototyping on
a laptop maybe someone sent me a csv or
something right um but that
when we're doing kind of this graduating
approach to machine learning step by
step um you know we may not have a csv
anymore maybe we're reading from
parque files on s3 or maybe we're using
you know athena to query snowflake or
whatever it is right so this is another
kind of small step in the direction of
production productionizing um which may
not you know in itself be
productionizing but it's what one
dimension of the types of things we need
to need to talk about um we may want to
schedule execution
okay and this serving an endpoint or
schedule execution i think is one of the
things that people
think
is definitive of productionizing or
operationalizing um but some of the
highest impact machine learning models
i've ever seen internally at companies
are models that have been delivered via
powerpoint presentations think about
a big tech company
that executive needs to make a decision
on what type of billboards they put on
which highways in which states right um
this is this costs a lot of money right
for
for big tech companies this is not
automated but they have all types of
machine learning models that that play
into this decision-making process um
which significantly impact roi um and
this is not scheduling a scheduled
execution right um this is something
that's you know hand delivered and and
spoken about um it's also not
necessarily automated on either side the
execution isn't automated and the
generation isn't automated right and yet
i think if you say this isn't
productionized because we haven't got an
endpoint
look maybe i'll give you that but
it defeats the point to say it isn't
productionized i suppose it's my point
it's definitively operationalized and
that's really what we're talking about
here how to get machine learning um to
impact uh
decision making right
um
i'm going to stop on freeze
dependencies i don't want to say
anything more about this as you know
i've been in dependency uh purgatory if
not hell for several months
um
uh but this the the struggle is is real
uh and particularly when moving between
local compute cloud compute making sure
that you have the same dependencies
moving back and forth um is incredibly
important when thinking about
operationalizing and productionizing uh
machine learning models
okay
ah one final point of course even after
you do all of this maybe you wanna a a b
test your models um do experiments in
parallel and then promote um a
challenger model to production if it
beats someone in production right so
these are all concerns that happen when
thinking about moving towards production
um each of which by itself may not be
productionized per se but you put a few
together in order to productionize um
and really that's all to say once again
that productionization or
operationalizing isn't just one one
thing it's a whole whole suite of tools
and techniques with the goal of um
either um
having an action automated or helping a
decision maker
uh make a business uh decision um so
just to be clear everything i've just
told you will fail all the time um and
the reason i want to make that clear is
because i want to make it incredibly
clear that the path to production is
incremental and iterative so uh
you either are or will be moving between
prototype and production constantly and
part of my life mission um for
scientists is to make sure that this
loop is as tight as possible that's one
of the reasons i'm excited to work on
these problems one of the reasons i'm
excited to work at metaflow um or with
with metaflow for metaflow as mediflow
um
is because i believe there's a huge
opportunity to uh time this loop and i
think metaflow before i joined did a
relatively good job and it's definitely
uh seems to be getting better um
so
kind of to wrap up this section i can't
i'm just going to move my
the camera to
the video bar um
what i really want to say is that
production readiness is a spectrum more
than that it's a multi-dimensional space
um and we need to be supporting projects
at all phases um
of of their life cycle so if there's a
project that's promising we want to then
be able to scale it to all the data that
the data scientist or machine learner
needs
um if predictions feed here into a
decision for support system we want
humans to be able to error correct it if
if needed this actually i'd almost
hesitate to reintroduce this term
into a common lexicon but this is a
question of cybernetics right of how
you know the pilot and the machine work
together and how we do our best work
while machines do their their best work
okay um
and and so we have a number of other use
cases here but i think i think i've i
think i've buried this point um that it
definitely is a multi-dimension
multi-dimensional space um so why am i
talking about all of this right when
we're here to talk about ml ops what
even is
emmalops right why does machine learning
need special treatment um and it's a
good question and that's why i'm asking
it can't we just fold um the ml needs of
software into existing devops best
practices right and i think the answer
is no and that's part of my thesis of
why this term ml ops once again it's a
macro trend of tools and practices and
conversations and
larping and
marketing that has brought this to
to the front but like big data like data
science like all of these terms i think
there is an underlying current that
that is worth looking at once we get rid
of all the market marketing bs and
that's kind of part of what i intend to
do this evening um
so first i'll answer these questions
then i'll start to talk about what a
modern technology stack for streamlined
ml processors uh looks like and then
we'll check briefly about how you can
start applying the stack in practice
uh
today um
so why does machine learning need
i love this this horrible figure um
so yeah why does ml and sorry just to be
clear by machine learning i actually i'm
not even talking about machine learning
um sorry um if anybody thought i would
be um i'm half joking what i mean by
that is we we use the machine the term
machine learning um for a lot of
different things when i talk about
machine learning powered applications or
machine learning learning powered
software
it could be a statistical inference
model it doesn't need to be a machine
learning model it could be just
software that's powered by data as well
i think more generally what we're all
talking about here when thinking about
mlobs
is not just the operations and the stack
for machine learning but it is for how
we think about and build
software that's powered by data now if
you want to limit that to fit and
predict and end points i'm chill with
that but i want to make clear that i
think kind of a broader world view um is
is potentially useful here i'm happy to
have that challenge actually excited to
have that challenged
um
we shared a slice of pizza for any
incoming challenges but um
so why does ml require a different a
different conversation okay so let's
just think about the job of
a non-machine learning software engineer
okay so on average i know there are edge
cases and outliers and that's the
problem with social media no i'm kidding
but writing traditional software on
average deals with well-defined narrowly
scoped inputs which the engineer can
exhaustively and cleanly model in in the
code whether that happens or not all the
time i'll leave that up to you um
but in effect what happens is the
engineer designs and builds uh the world
wherein the software operates okay
um in distinct and direct contrast to
this a defining feature of machine
learning powered applications is that
they're actually exposed constantly
and directly to a large amount of messy
real-world data which is just too
complicated uh and or complex to be
modeled modeled by hand okay so what
this means is that
machine learning applications are
actually fundamentally different from
traditional software um
you know but that's that's relative
that's relatively abstract what i want
to do now is think about what the
implications are as to
how such software should be developed
and by whom okay
so
data changes everything because machine
learning applications as i've said are
directly
exposed to the constant constantly
changing real world through data okay
whereas traditional software operates in
a simplified static abstract world which
is directly constructed by the developer
what's the implication of this
or what else do we have involved machine
learning software needs to be developed
through cycles of experimentation this
is due to
sure it's gonna say i've been saying jew
but it's due because we're in new york
due to the constant exposure to data we
don't learn the behavior of machine
learning apps through logical reasoning
alone but through empirical observation
okay so we have this exp this
this defining characteristic of
experimentation so what happens then
then what happens is that the skill set
and the background of people building
the applications gets realigned okay so
while it is still effective to express
applications in code the emphasis
actually shifts and i think that's
probably why a lot of us are here today
the emphasis shifts to data and
experimentation that's more akin to
empirical science rather than
traditional software engineering okay
now
i want to make clear that this approach
isn't isn't new
um and as many of us
will will recognize there has there's a
decades-long tradition of data centric
programming okay um so
we have our studio of course uh matlab
jupiter notebooks excel
um and i think one of the ogs was
actually mathematica no notebooks right
um
which um
essentially this is a whole suite of
data centric ides
that people have been using since at
least the the 80s and came to the fore
in the
past couple couple of decades right
um
now why aren't these
necessarily
yet uh useful for
operationalizing or productionizing
machine learning models whereas they're
great for prototyping right um
one reason is because they're relatively
insular um but i think there are there
are probably three things or four things
clearly that we need to talk about um
a lot of the time what we're doing now
what we're talking about the scale of
operations are actually um is two orders
of magnitude larger than in early
data-centric environments
not only is the data larger but models
for example deep learning models
much larger than before okay
second thing that changes modern machine
learning applications need to be
carefully orchestrated um
got a huge increase in the complexity of
such applications which can require
interconnected steps um
essentially
we need better software paradigms such
as uh dags directed ac graphs right
which perhaps weren't necessary when uh
we were using um mathematica notebooks
back in the day this isn't to say that
the data centric paradigm and literate
programming can't be extremely useful
here i want to make that very clear um
but we do need a suite
of other tools and this is kind of what
why ml ops has arisen uh in in our
opinion anyway as i've mentioned briefly
we need robust versioning for data for
models for code and preferably even the
internal state of applications right so
i want you to be thinking like get on
steroids to answer questions that will
arise such as what changed
why did something break
how do two iterations compare who did
what and when okay so we want to be
taking snapshots all throughout right um
now the fourth incredibly important
reason is that the applications uh need
to be integrated into surrounding
business systems so ideas can be tested
and validated in the real world in a
controlled manner okay
so
in these two lists
two important trends
collide okay so
on the one case um in the one case we
have the long tradition of data centric
uh programming um and on the other we're
facing the needs of modern large-scale
business applications right um and i
think either paradigm is insufficient
for what we need to do um i mean
it would
i wouldn't advise anyone to
build a modern machine learning
application in excel i mean maybe you've
tried and maybe it works but i i'd
suggest that's in that's an edge case um
and
in the same breath um it'll be
ridiculous to claim that a data
intensive application
is similar to a run-of-the-mill
microservice which can be built with
github docker kubernetes
these types of things right so in this
modern production infrastructure for
data sciences where kind of this
envelopsy space um
has arisen and i think whether we use
the term ml ops or not i honestly don't
care but what we really need to figure
out is what is happening in in in this
space um when we have the collision of
um all of these different different
trends um and where to move from here
okay so essentially what we need um is a
new path that allows all the results of
data centric programming models and data
science applications to be deployed on
modern um
infrastructure i'm doing gestures like
this to just
looks like um you know about to
kick box with max [ __ ] or something um
but to gesture which side of the
triangle i'm i'm going up but if i'm
mirror imaged in your display i mean
just just flip me back okay
so um
having
ascertained kind of why ml needs special
treatment um
i mean a good question to ask
which is why i ask it now the reason i
ask it is because people have asked me
it so many times as well is um what does
a modern technology stack for
streamlined ml processes
look like and i can't i'm not going to
go into all the different i mean there
are 100 different tools for each layer
in this stack right
and that like i meant to exaggerate but
i don't even think i did um
okay so the question is what does the
stack even
even look like right um and as we saw
before um when you're going from
prototype to production you're suddenly
you know interacting with larger data
trying to get more compute having to
orchestrate things you've got versioning
you've got software architecture you've
got model ops feature engineering model
development of the top right and
the question is
should anybody
ever
be accountable or responsible for this
entire stack and i i personally like
maybe there are some legends out there
who can do it like 10x whatevers
but i definitively think no and most
scientists i know don't want to focus on
everything here um arguably the pattern
we've seen is that most data scientists
want to build models right um and and
and and work with features um and and
have the data that's ready to to explore
it and all of these
these types of things and figure out
what's happening um in in in the data
right the reason data is at the bottom
here of course is because we're talking
about data infrastructure not
necessarily the model that the data
science um constantly interacts with um
but essentially what we've seen time and
time again
is that we require a huge amount of
infrastructure for what happens at the
bottom and data scientists really
want to be able to focus on the top um
so what i'm really interested in um is
building tools and helping people use
tools that allow
that allow i mean like that allowed tens
of millions of scientists um
to focus on on the models and the
features and and the data while having
access to all the infrastructural uh
layers at at the bottom
um one example that
i might show you later
i might not actually um
is when we look at some metaflow code at
the end as an example um when you
prototype code uh workflows in in
metaflow you do it all locally if you
have a step that is becoming
computationally intensive um
you know such as um
training on a large large large data set
whatever it may be um
you can
at that step using kubernetes decorator
or at batch aws batch in order or at gpu
to allocate that step allocate um
infrastructural cloud resources for for
that step once it's set up right but the
whole point of that
that paradigm is so that once your
machine learning engineer has set up the
compute for you to use as a data
scientist you don't need to change any
code except for one line and it may just
be uncommenting something that's that's
there actually um and that's one way
that i really think um
will help with this
iteration cycle between prototype and
production making the ability to send
things to the cloud and back with the
same dependencies with the same data or
larger data whatever it is uh specifying
it in
in my case idiomatic in idiomatic python
um but of course in whatever language of
choice without having to delve deep into
like
nested channels or you know all types of
crazy um configuration files
um
so i think one more story that not we've
talked about going from prototype to
production but thinking about how a data
scientist may interact with all these
layers right um so we have our data
scientists here
um and they're using their laptop to
access a cloud workstation where they've
got vs code or jupyter or whatever it
may be um okay so they need to access
data which locally would have been a csv
um but now um as we're trying to
productionize things or operationalize
things actually going from our snowflake
from our data warehouse right
then we need to interact with compute
let's say i'm doing stuff on
um
pick cloud provider of choice i'm not
going to give any of the mind check and
currently um but we need to access that
from our local workstation um and figure
out how our data warehouse interacts
with that as well
certainly if we have several several
steps we require some sort of
orchestration
to happen there
then when we're running a whole bunch of
stuff in parallel for example we
definitely need to log and version
everything that's that's happening
and store them automatically
and that this once again is an iterative
cycle where data scientists can develop
and test and iterate as i've written
here on uh all their projects as rapidly
as possible
so that's really the goal of of thinking
about um
how to operationalize ml ops essentially
okay um so the question remains um and
we can talk a lot more about each of
these points afterwards but how how can
you start applying the stack in practice
today okay
so
i want to ask a few questions to answer
these questions if you're considering a
solution
i want to know
i want you to ask does the solution
provide a delightful user experience for
data scientists and machine learning
engineers um that relationship is key as
well and something culturally
we've seen you know work across several
verticals um in some places it's still
pretty pretty challenging thinking about
division of labor in the space
i think we can look to
the modern data stack and analytics
the analytics stack um
for lessons
on how best practices tools and division
of labor can work in such a technical
space and that can inform the
relationship between data scientists and
machine learning engineers
um but we need to ask that question does
the solution provide a delightful user
experience to data scientists and ml
engineers then does the solution provide
first class support for the rapid
iterative development and frictionless a
b testing
super key
third foundational question does the
solution integrate with your existing
infrastructure in particular uh to the
foundational data compute and
orchestration layouts okay so these are
all
foundational and key concerns you need
to be thinking about when adopting any
new technologies for your ml stack and
there are
a a bunch out there right um so i as
i've said i work on metaflow at uh out
of bounds
um and maybe i should say a bit more of
that i so i'm head of devrel
um
developer relations and community at
outer bounds
um
where
we're trying to build
software and products that help with all
the concerns that i've mentioned today
and metaflow is the main open source
framework we're working on currently but
we have a few other things um in in the
pipeline that i'm very excited about but
of course there's also vertex ai there's
sagemaker there's azure machine learning
studio um
all of these are definitely worth
worth looking into right
um to to ground
this somewhat abstract conversation
um
in kind of practical reality and and
code i thought to just give an example
of of mediflow with some of these
concerns
um
so essentially
um what the way we
encourage data scientists to work is to
to write the python code that they
they they know and love right um and so
you can take your notebook code and uh
refactor it as workflows um with a
pythonic idiomatic pythonic
user-friendly
syntax which you can see here and then
you'll save this as myflow dot pi and
run it as as such this is a very basic
example where we just have a start step
where we import um
pandas and a data frame and then end it
okay
uh then of course
you need to do a lot more right so if
you're going to
if you want to run 100 experiments
concurrently independent experiments um
at scale on using cloud-based
infrastructure um the way you would do
that uh with metaflow is not so
different to the to the previous uh
example you have your start step you'll
have an n step down the bottom um and
you'll just use this quark for each in
order to uh massively parallelize this
this training step and as i mentioned
before you can um
assign i could actually
just assign a kubernetes
cluster using at kubernetes here um what
we're actually doing in this example is
we're assigning uh the memory resources
there and when i
um execute the um the code from the
command line i'm then saying with
kubernetes for the entire thing but um
let's say you only had one step which
required um something huge maybe you
just send that that step up as well
that's relatively straightforward
um
how we think about versioning everything
just gets version
automatically um and um you can see here
anything you assign to self essentially
uh the metadata um gets gets stored and
it's easily accessible after the fact
and i'd be excited to chat about um
kind of the ins and outs of that and how
you access these things the cool thing
there is that it actually helps you to
to build um experiment trackers yourself
as well um as i mentioned before um we
really need tools for fast data access
um so that's something we've worked on
and
integrate with most forms
of data that you'll need as as well um
so those are just a few
of the kind of ways we've thought about
it in terms of writing code as kind of a
practical
example
i i do maybe i'll
play this um
this is an example of
um i mentioned experiment trackers and
visualization um we are deeply visual
creatures and so
we've built some things called metaflow
cards which allow any data scientist
essentially um
to visualize what's happening throughout
any of the flows that they they write so
you can see this is the image data of
new york city taxi
data set you can actually see down the
bottom there was the dag
you've got all types of artifacts there
you can see whatever's happening now
where
changing the code slightly and
executing it let's see what happens here
right so
this is um we're clicking pretty quickly
through this gui um but the reason i
wanted to freeze frame on this this
tells you all about where your
computation's happening um how intense
how intensive it is
and then
um the other thing i wanted to show for
anyone who's more interested in the
machine learning side of things it
allows you pretty easily to um
to uh generate
um whatever visualization such as your
roc curve here um
i may preempt a particular question um i
i said you can build your own experiment
to track experimentation trackers here a
lot of people already use
experimentation trackers such as
weights and biases or comet uh or
neptune right
um and i mentioned earlier that i think
software needs to interoperate with
kind of
the most used tools out there and for
that reason at metaflow we do um we have
integrations with um explicit
integrations
with two out of three experiment
trackers and uh some
um ones which are easy to generate
yourself uh relatively straightforwardly
with the others as as well um but i do i
do i can't stress enough how important i
think um interoperability is at at the
moment and we've seen
how it has been
there's a question like how many vendors
do you want to speak to really like if
you have 20 steps and you have someone
different for each do you is that type
of interoperability
um
worthwhile and the answer may be no um
but it depends how how small n is
essentially i think in the analytics
space right um
with tools such as
dbt and snowflake in the modern data
stack um
the interoperability there has has come
a long way um and i do think this is
probably another point to make i've used
that space and a few others as analogies
or tethers but i do think when trying to
figure out what what on earth is
happening in our space and to forge a
path forward uh looking at other spaces
can
can be useful um and seeing where those
analogies break down can also also be
useful
um
i'm gonna i'm gonna end on that note i'd
if you if you're interested in this type
of stuff come and chat with me on on our
community slack um
which is right here slack dot out of
bounds dot co
um
once again i'd love to thank jared and
the whole team for hosting this great
meet up and thank um nom and ecohealth
alliance for for sponsoring it and um
thank you all for attending and i'm
looking forward to hearing your
questions and chatting thank you very
much hugo let's see if a little round of
golf clap or emoji collapse actually
since we uh we're in emoji land no one
knows you're golf clapping they need to
make a golf clap emoji then the world
will be complete that is the best idea
you've ever had i think thank you i
agree i agree
yes so um everyone i'll give some
chances to ask some questions um
a few already and you sort of talked
about it but
talk about all these different stacks
and everything
how do you string them together is that
metaphor that string them together is
there one thing that does it all yet or
are you still relate are you still
relying on different things
yeah i am
i do use metaflow to string it together
and that's the way i would suggest doing
it there are some other tools but i will
i'll actually what i'm going to do
i need to get this right
i want to just share my screen again and
show you
something
um it's a schematic which i think will
help think
think through this
um and i will actually
share this
in
slack
as well
um this is actually something i
published recently
um
about how thinking about joining
ml ops with data ops as essentially how
the modern data stack can be um combined
with with the machine learning stack um
can you see my screen
yep
so
i you can check out
this um
more generally um but one way to
think about i mean this is one project
we've worked on where metaflow
essentially provides
the backbone for the rest of the code
and when you want to transform your data
you can access dbt directly from it
because it's all python right you can
access snowflake comet for um
your experiment trackers uh reckless for
doing testing the actual recommendation
system and then deploying it to
sagemaker now the reason i wanted to
show this particular example is because
jacopo
um our collaborator who who worked on
this you can see his schematic of it
actually has all the code uh
here um
i've just posted that in slack as well
um
to show how with metaflow or in any
other similar tool you can actually uh
do do this type of thing um
so i think
that's the way i'd suggest doing it in
all honesty a lot of
places i've seen
hand roll how to do it in internally
right so that's essentially as i said a
lot of this is pattern recognition so
seeing how people hand roll things
internally and then providing frameworks
which allow people to to do this is
is key
but the short answer is yes metaphor is
the best solution
so it seems like metaphor is like a nice
dad again we always like dags here
how do you get it to run on a schedule
right you want to run every day every
week every month every year or different
cadences is that something built into
metaflow is that something you need to
schedule like let's see you don't want
that big machine sitting there all week
long you just want to use it for sunday
night like what how do you handle all
that
yeah exactly so we've got integrations
with all types of uh cloud providers to
allow you to schedule things pretty
pretty precisely uh doing it um but yeah
it is baked into metaflow to allow you
to
schedule yourself anywhere also um and
i'll actually
what i'll
do is
is it okay if i just paste
things into slack that answer these
questions as well
provide technical so this is
uh literally a page on how to schedule
uh metaflow flows
cool we might have to have you come do a
whole day a whole workshop in medflow
one day that that would be really fun
man and i because i just gave one um
at scipy um and so i've given this four
hour workshop actually on
full stack data science with mediflow
but i've given it twice before
virtually at odsc but this is the first
time i did it in a room of a hundred
people
it feels nice right it was amazing
um and so what i've just linked to as
well
um
actually shows you i really like this um
as i mentioned we work with a lot of
decorators but we do have an app
scheduled decorator um to run on on step
functions if you uh
want to do that which um
pretty much requires you to do not much
else
good
then i guess sticking in metaflow you
know i know metaphor supports r third
reticulate what about other language oh
that's well that's using r to call
metaflow but how do you use r or julia
or sql
inside metaflow steps like how do you
recreate the r environment or julia
reppel what do you do
um that's a good question i we did have
an our story previously which we've
which is on on the side currently so we
actually don't support r
yeah
um there are always are ways to do it
but there's definitely a lot more
support for python oh yep what about
what about having to make a custom c
plus plus or julia or
name it rust or sql do you have steps
for that is it just everything's in
python everything's pythonic currently
okay
cool
um
and let's talk about you mentioned dbt a
few times i know that's that's so hot
right now um okay tell us a little bit i
know it's not a tangential to your topic
can you tell us a little bit about um
dbt
yeah i'm i'm i think what dbt has done
in terms of i mean
in terms of building a community and a
tool and a suite of best practices
um
to allow
analytics and data transformation to
take place is
is really strong and it's allowed people
to communicate across
the entire community as well which i
think it isn't only about the tool right
it's about creating a class i mean we
talk about like dbt analytics engineers
and that type of stuff right so it's
actually created a a class in a in a
community um so i think the way it's
made it
easy ergonomic and elegant for people to
do their transformations has
has changed changed the space and i
think a tool like that or a set of tools
in the machine learning space would
actually
come along
bring us a long way it's not clear that
the patterns are
as similar though or that
maybe a set of different tools right
what makes dbt so much nicer than
writing pandas code or dplyr code or
other stuff what makes it so much more
like you said it's more afraid the word
to use but so much nicer why do you like
have you ever tried to write pandas code
no i ran a lot deep player not pandas um
that's a good question i think um
so
i've never used
d player to deal with large amounts of
data so i can't really speak speak to
that but the way
i can
you know we all can get dbt interacting
with our really large-scale databases
with snowflake all of these types of
things i'm not certain how that would
work in d play i'd actually ask ask you
that are there affordances of dbt with
respect to that maybe d player
lags on i don't know i don't know enough
about dbt but part of the reason that
was my question actually to you trying
to figure out about dvt um but i know
like so d plier could work on snowflake
it just it translates your d player
commands to snowflake commands it can
work on parquet files it translates it
to arrow it can work on postcards
because it translates it to sql
um so yeah so it just works in back end
agnostic so i guess is it the is it the
fact that dbt works on large data it's
like the coding style is nicer than
pando's because i honestly i have little
experience of pandas i know it's more
like base r but um what makes it nicer
than that just a
friendlier language yeah i've i i've
definitely found it friendly but i i'd
half joke about pandas wes is not
watching so it's okay
well and my pandas isn't incredible
yeah
um i think i think we'd all agree that
um
it can be bloated in some some
directions but that's a minor
knit in a tool that's
essentially
had entire industries built upon it as
well right yep um
yeah no it's a good question i need to
i'd need to figure out a bit more about
what's happening with dplyr now to
answer answer that well i i do think
um
on top of the tool
the
the shared common language the framework
the community has built and the best
practices is is a huge part of it also
okay
yeah cool uh there's a comment more than
a question here but will landau who
wrote the targets package in r which is
essentially like make for r is working
with meta flow to somehow um combine
them somehow uh so i guess would you do
you have any news or is this a secret to
you even that's that's actually a secret
to me so i'm excited to to hear more
okay so what to wait in fact uh so will
spoke at the
meet up over a year ago so maybe he's
overdue about to wrangle him again and
get him to divulge any secrets he has or
otherwise everyone's just
go hit will on twitter and ask him
what's going on what's going on just
drag it out of him
what tools do you like in the data
versioning space and why
wow
um
i
or data versioning well no matter i
think metaflow's the
the way to do this um you know honestly
you've got to show your work
what's that yeah well as you know my
math teachers tell you show your work
show your work give us your reasoning
why is why is that better than um
pachyderm why is that better this we had
a talk a few months ago about actually
know him he gave a talk about another
database that does data versioning so
what makes metaflow versus pachyderm
versus this other one whose name i'm
forgetting why metaflow
yeah so i think because for me
mediflow the versioning aspect of it you
get for free with everything else i
don't necessarily see why i'd introduce
a new tool into
my
my framework right so as i showed before
when
what one of the reasons i'm so excited
about or i was initially very excited
about metaflow is
there's a question around experiment
experimentation trackers and i think
they're incredibly interesting and they
come down to some of the versioning
story we need to tell as well right in
that
experiment trackers solve a very
important concern my
personal
take is that it's a downstream concern
of the version in question essentially
um if you're able to version models data
code all of these things well
you can then build experiment trackers
on
on top of that but you need to have
logged absolutely everything and
the reason i'm telling the story in this
roundabout way is because i was excited
when i heard with mediflow you you
actually get that get that for free on
top of everything else and then you can
build your your experiment trackers on
on top of it
okay
all right and the the the company name i
couldn't think of was dalt they're the
one who has a data version another
version database oh
yeah so gnome gave a talk about it uh in
may so you can go to
nyhacker.org and check out the video
awesome yeah
um someone's asking are you what's your
thoughts on aim it's an experiment
checker um aimstack.oh that's in the i
actually don't
don't know about it so let's let's look
at it in real time yeah paul share your
screen let's hope that's a good link
i mean
the big problem of course is that all
websites say the same things all the
time now right
let's see what we can
see it's easy to use great i love that
it's supercharged not sure what that
means it's open source
i like that although that can mean
different things it's an ml experiment
tracker logs your training runs very
good enables a beautiful ui to compare
them and an api to query them
programmatically all those things
sound fantastic um i also like
like this that the visuals look great
um
so
what is their
business model if they're open source
i'm actually asking this for in like
when i try to
yeah
interesting so it's not clear it without
having used it at all it's not clear to
me whether
it's a useful tool but it looks it looks
nice and i actually
like the fact that i've already got
strong signals of what it interoperates
with
as well which is a really important um
concern of mine and
and all of ours um
so
promising at the start i wonder no i'm
not going to look at the github stars
that's because i'm not going to
legitim legitimate that type of behavior
fair enough
um i see a few more people are typing
until then i'm going to
make you talk to us about some metaphor
alternatives
why not airflow why not
all these other ones luigi why not this
and that i'm not sure luigi's little
thing yeah why not star flow
any any other thing from from star flow
um
so
airflow's a great orchestrator right um
but
as far as i can tell it's definitely far
more useful for data engineers than data
scientists trying to iterate very
rapidly um and go from prototype to
production um so one affordance that i
think is very important that metaflo has
that airflow doesn't is the ability to
um
rapidly
um parallelize training and train a
thousand models at once
if you want and and build that into your
dag which isn't an affordance that
airflow has it may at some some point so
i'm not saying that you know the
wonderful people at australia won't
won't get get to that um
i do think
um
one of the biggest selling points
for metaflo from a lot of users that
i've i've spoken spoken to
um
is the ability to write
only python and sql code essentially
when you need to write your sequel right
the fact that you don't need to um
use any
sdk or learn a whole bun bunch of new
stuff writing classes in idiomatic
python um and that's i mean that sounds
nice right but let's think about what it
means in in in practice right it means
if it's you save an hour a day or
something like that that
that's incredibly valuable to a company
but it means you're not banging your
head against the wall right
all the time and i think in terms of
once again tightening that
iteration loop
um between prototype and production the
ability to write something in your own
language is incredibly incredibly
important
and that's i mean we can talk about the
other flows we can talk about
you know cube flow
for example right which
even for you know really technical
people like getting kubeflow up and
running like no data scientists
should ever have to do that as far as
i'm concerned
perhaps if you're working data science
consulting um and you actually need to
be really full stack in in some way but
maybe you need an ml engineer on your
team as well to be honest at some point
um that's why we are hiring linux admins
who are very good you're real yeah
fantastic yeah um
yeah so i think that's that and on top
of that the the decorator-based nature
of it to be able to change your steps
and send things to different places
access different types of data whenever
you whenever you want um is definitely a
value proposition i thought a lot of
data scientists talked about
cool
and while you were describing this to us
gnome chimed in the all websites are the
same thing he just uh sent the another
question aqueduct hq
yeah let's check that out let's see
what's in there
so and gnome's question actually was
how do you tell the difference and it's
actually incredibly tough i actually
think one of the best ways is to
look at look at this most people are on
most companies are on slack or discord
these days to go in there but
look you can get on a call with a sales
rep and still not know the difference
after that call right
so the struggle the struggle is real
huh
i like the name aqueduct
they have decorators
they connect to similar processes
fascinating
some
i mean yeah this this looks like a
an interesting project absolutely i
would definitely join their slack
channel i um
so let me say
i i think
they have relatively they have three
around 300 github stars we're not going
to legitimize that you said well so
let me actually be very explicit i'm not
going to
legitimize using github stars as a proxy
for usage
i will
use it as a proxy for awareness i
actually think it is is it is a
relatively good proxy for awareness
um
but not for usage i think okay
um
that isn't to say this is a really i
mean this tool looks looks very
interesting um
i wonder who they
yeah
cool well i'm definitely going to check
it out at least when
we're doing our next swot analysis
nice
uh so then we have another question
um
really two parts because she asked and
she clarified so um
i being joyce i teach data science
students so i think a lot about if what
i'm teaching them will prepare them well
for industry what pain points do you see
new data scientists encountering when
they begin dealing with ml in the real
world to put another way
it seems a lot of the stats you're
describing aren't conceptually different
from what students are doing in our
studio just more powerful so welcoming
any thoughts
if you need to read if it's easier for
you to read than here it's in slack from
joyce yeah yeah i am i am reading it
um
i wonder
how do you think about this jared
because i i do feel like the steps i
described are
quite different from
our studio um
different from our studio but like
almost everything here we could do with
targets let's say
right
you know targets it builds the dag
automatically and the nice thing i like
about targets is all you have to do is
just a a downstream step
applies a function to an upstream step
and it automatically draws a dag
and
it can automatically you know i can say
okay this step pulls the data from the
database this step fits a model this
step publishes the results somewhere
you know targets does at least all the
dag stuff
it doesn't necessarily do the
you know experiment recording or
the scheduler you can run it you can put
a cron job on it but to me you know
at least to me my viewers a lot of the
stuff it's all about the dag and targets
is another tag written in our code
instead of writing python code
obviously you know ml flow or metaflow
does
more than just the dag but that seemed
to me when i'm looking at these things
it seems like that's the bulk i'm
guessing that's what's just coming on
here too i i understand that and maybe i
can then
not knowing enough about targets i can't
speak to targets i can speak to our
studio in that
i think
depending what you're doing in
in academia and research i do think a
lot of the time as i said the scale of
operations will be significantly larger
or can be significantly larger in
business applications particularly not
only data but in models um
the orchestration is absolutely key and
that speaks to the dags um the
versioning story as well so robust
versioning for data model and code
um
and then the most significant thing
perhaps is
integrating these
ml powered apps into like business logic
and business systems right so if i'm so
maybe this this will help um
[Music]
joyce
if i want to like run 100 models
experiment 100 models in parallel while
i've got one in production if i have one
that is performing better than one in
production how do i switch it out
without you know breaking up absolutely
everything in in the business system
right so i think those four in
particular scale of operations
orchestration
versioning
and
embedded in business systems
i'll give you the
um
one of those works like scale like
target's nice thing not to go competing
against metaphor but targets for your
identification you can actually run it
on a cluster and different stuff around
different steps look at targets i think
you're gonna like it it's um it's very
cool it's uh i think you should add that
to your that's your swot analysis i
think you'll really enjoy looking at
targets yeah i'm really excited to
check it out man yeah um and if will is
indeed working on somehow integrating
targets of mediflow i think that's going
to be a really nice move that would be
very cool yeah
and just to be clear like my my
intention isn't necessarily to convert
everyone to mediflow but to start start
this conversation so that you all
convert to metaphor
yeah um
cool i think that
everything there is a comment from
patrick just talking about the decorator
design pattern you know that's common
dexter prefect metaflow yeah absolutely
yeah i didn't i didn't mean to suggest
that was unique to oh i don't think it
did i think you just were talking about
because i know i'm found aquaduct don't
use decorators or some decorators are
being used all over the place and
decorators is a really cool um feature
that makes life easier i did see someone
try to implement them in r and but it
hasn't taken off nearly the same weight
as in python and
have really been a huge deal yeah
absolutely yeah
beyond just the flows you know it's
useful for so many things outside of
that
um actually last question can you tell
us for the people who don't know here
tell us what a decorator is if that's
sort of in your wheelhouse
yeah um i think the best way
to describe it
is a function
that acts on another function so it
changes the behavior of a function um so
the example here or the example i gave
would be
if you don't decorate it with kubernetes
it just runs it locally whereas if you
put the app kubernetes decorator on it
it changes where that code actually
executes
that's really cool
yeah
so is it does it essentially create a
new function that calls your function as
part of it
is that what's like the unknown i think
that's how it's implemented in metaflow
and and in most places i would want to
just
let me
i want to get this right
[Music]
well he is researching i'll tell
everyone if you have one last minute
question we're going to wrap up soon we
want to slide in one at the last
deadline like indiana jones grabbing us
fedora after the door is closing now is
your chance
yeah so it is it yeah a design pattern
in python that ours allows anyone to add
new functionality to an existing
function or object without modifying the
structure of the initial one
so i'm going to guess having not used it
much what happens is when you put that
in and you source your python script
a parser has to go through and it finds
this and it grabs a function underneath
it and then
wraps it and exposes it as another
function without you really having to do
anything yeah for the most part
cool does it work in notebooks
yeah
okay
very cool to know so i know they're i
the decorators on r had to only be
worked in like scripts you sourced it
didn't work interactively so the fact
that these work inside notebooks is
really really cool
interesting that's a really nice touch
okay
cool so here's what i'm gonna do i'm
gonna make the closing announcements
just sort of just a reminder about some
things i announced if there happens to
be another question that sneaks in we'll
allow one only one um if there's more
than one please go into the monthly
meetup chat and ask hugo there if we
were in person i say let's go to the bar
afterwards you could ask you go there if
you were also if you're virtual though
that wouldn't have helped you so please
do um
chime in here if you have questions
so just a reminder to everybody we are
looking for meetup space so we could
hold these beautiful in-person virtual
meetups again
if your company or your your agency or
your office or wherever you have space
your university would like to give us
some space somewhere in the city let us
know and folks always we're always going
to do this both virtual and um in person
in fact the last two months we did in
person we used youtube live as our
simulcast
let me know how you think about that
did people like that did you do you
prefer zoom do you like youtube live do
you like some other platform we are open
to experimenting um youtube live worked
i think people people attended it and it
worked for me technologically i was able
to hook my camera up to it but let me
know folks if you have if you didn't
like it for some reason or if you had
trouble signing up or whatever let me
know and let me know if you have space
very important
the nyr videos from this past june are
up at rstats.ai so go check those out 20
some talks it was
a really fun conference again both in
person and virtual and likewise december
1st through 2nd well november 30th
through december 2nd it's so hard to
combine two months we have are in
government our and friends in government
maybe they'll even be a metaflo talk or
workshop want to discuss hugo see if
he's allowed back in the country by then
um
yeah so now hugo is gonna have to
eventually go back to his homeland at
some point maybe i'll come back here for
this
it's on
october
november 30th through december 2nd
it's possible
the one in october is shining production
in newcastle
uh that should be a fun time and then
hugo mentioned odsc for those of you
that don't know odsc is a pretty cool
conference pretty large held around the
world the next one is coming up in
november i want to say in california i
might be wrong in the month i'm pretty
sure it's november i'm speaking there
but i don't remember the month or where
i'm bonuses to be there um but yeah so
odsc is coming up that's another cool
conference um that you know friends of
the meetup that we really like
so
um remember
in my rstats.ai for
the conference videos and my hack are
for meetups from videos from this meetup
are in government coming up in december
shiny production coming in october
odsc i believe in november don't quote
me on that i get a better book my flight
um and jobs if you're looking to hire
post in the jobs posting channel
all right
so thank you everyone for attending
thank you hugo for your presentation
answering all of our questions that was
terrific
um folks you want to see hugo here again
uh
asking a lot of questions and meet up so
many questions that he has to come
present on something
please tell us everything
uh we'll get him here anyway he'll we'll
find some other way to get him back here
anyway but definitely ask as many
questions as possible i'll be on on the
slack in the next couple of days and
just reach out
all right wonderful well everyone
doesn't have a nice emoji clap for hugo
thank you very much for being here it
had a lot i had a really great time hope
everyone else did too
thanks jared thanks everyone
bye